deux parties et moi j'ai bien sûr suivi
très très très près ce dossier je peux
et ce sont des partenaires sur d'autres
sujets j'ai évoqué le sujet de
l'abonnement le sujet de l'utilisation
de la plateforme nous travaillons depuis
longtemps avec bien avant la loi sur les
droits voisins je peux vous assurer que
ce qu'ils ont signé c'est parce qu'ils
ont considéré que c'était un bon accord
pour eux et que les termes étaient
justes les termes étaient équitables et
qu'ils avaient un intérêt en valeur pour
leur entreprise de les 6000 c'est
absolument dans cet esprit que ce fut
fait je vais arrêter
puisque j'ai beaucoup de colère ont des
questions ou mais vous pensez bien que
quand on signe un accord c'est pas
forcément parce qu'on le trouve bon
c'est parce que parfois entre zéro et un
peu on préfère un peu voilà
sur leurs pattes objectivement nous
avons passé deux années à négocier
pas con préfacé un sujet très important
nous avons passé deux années à négocier
et je sais les conditions la façon dont
nous avons construit les accords car en
réalité si le texte que certains d'entre
vous d'ailleurs ont porté devant le
parlement n'était pas c'est assez clair
l'exécution pour des plateformes
notamment la nôtre où il n'y a pas cette
action de curation de contenu mais où
des acteurs eu décide librement et
gratuitement d'utiliser nos plateformes
vous savez bien que c'était une
disposition est une façon d'évoluer
extrêmement compliqué on a passé deux
ans à négocier
moi je souhaitais qu'on arrive à trouver
un accord le plus vite possible ces deux
années ont été je crois pour le voir le
dire de façon très objective très
constructives et les accords en tout cas
quand je parle avec les patrons de ces
groupes ou le patron pierre louette le
président de l'alliance il me semble
qu'ils sont satisfaits des négociations
qui l'ont lu d'autant je le rappelle que
parallèlement de façon dissociée nous
l'avons proposé d'autres services
facebook news aidant vous le verrez très
prochainement nous annoncerons l'arrivée
de ce service en france qui rend un très
grand service pour les éditeurs et vous
l'a dit aussi pour les utilisateurs de
nos plateformes
passer la parole mes collègues mais
j'avais une question à vous poser vous
concernant les outils de contrôle vous
avez insisté sur le fait que les
utilisateurs avaient la possibilité de
choisir d'aider des outils de contrôle
totale bien entendu ça n'empêche pas
néanmoins que
la société elle même des outils de 2,2
de contrôle
sur la question des flux d'information
du type d'informations qui circulent
même si vous n'êtes pas éditeur mais en
tout cas qui circulent sur notamment
facebook il ya une espèce de pas citer
sur la réalité des contrôles que vous
exercez vous
à l'intérieur du réseau social et je
voudrais attirer enfin vous poser de
questions sur deux éléments de contrôle
pour lequel on a très peu d'informations
c'est les médiateurs est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire combien de médiateurs
francophones interviennent sur le réseau
facebook et sur la transparence des
algorithmes comment est mise en évidence
telle ou telle information
pour un utilisateur lambda sans se
parler de l'utilisation des outils que
peut choisir le le litige intervient
alors sur ce sujet en effet vase de la
modération disons des contenus qui sont
sûres sur la plateforme
nous avons en effet des règles que nous
appelons les standards de la communauté
qui sont des règles qui définissent le
type de contenu qui ne peuvent ou ne
peuvent pas être publiés sur la
plateforme facebook et instagram
et nous avons développé et engager des
moyens je crois considérable pour que
ces règles soient respectées
ces moyens sont de deux ordres le
président d'abord des moyens
technologiques
et des moyens humains je vais venir
depuis maintenant
l'ensemble des investissements sur ses
efforts de modération technologique et
humain représente un investissement de
13 milliards de dollars au cours de la
seule année 2000 21 c 5 milliards de
dollars qui ont été investis
premier pilier a été de développer des
outils technologiques fondé sur
l'intelligence artificielle
et les technologies et notamment de
diplômes big machine learning en
particulier développées par notre
laboratoire d'intelligence artificielle
ici à paris qui atteint principaux
laboratoires privés d'intelligence
artificielle en europe des outils qui
permettent de bloquer
proactivement des contenus qui ne
respectent pas nos règles et donc ils
n'ont rien à faire sur nos plateformes
c'est à dire qu'ils sont bloqués
à priori avant que vous puissiez les
voir ce qui a été un changement
fondamental pour nous puisque si nous
avions eu cette discussion il ya six ans
l'essentiel de la modération était poste
et signalés par les utilisateurs
c'est un effort financier et
technologique extrêmement importante qui
a conduit à des résultats extrêmement
probant je vous donne deux exemples
aujourd'hui les contenus à caractère
terroriste ou les contenus à caractère
de propagande terroriste son beau bloqué
proactivement par ces outils
technologiques extrêmement puissant et
performant à hauteur de 99 6%
pour les contenus de haine qui sont un
débat majeur des sociétés aujourd'hui en
tout cas les chiffres le monde ceux du
dernier trimestre 2009 21 plus de 93%
des contenus de m sont bloqués désormais
proactivement par ces outils avec une
croissance absolument
majeur au cours des dernières années
nous publions également un autre
indicateur qu'on appelle l'indicateur de
prévalence c'est à dire sur 10000
contenu combien vous voyez où vous
pouvez voir encore des contenus de haine
sur les contenus de haine ce taux de
prévalence est de 0 03 % c'était sur
10000 contenu vous pouvez voir peu près
trois contenus de haine
ça c'est l'effort technologique
toutes les recherches d'ailleurs que
nous avons fait pour améliorer ses
systèmes ont été rendus public est
partagé par les grands acteurs des
giteau du monde pour qu'ils puissent en
bénéficier
la modération humaines et le 2e pilier
elle a toujours eu lieu nous avons
aujourd'hui quarante mille personnes
dans le monde qui travaille sur la
sécurité de nos plateformes et 15000
modérateur dans plus de 70 langues nous
ne donnons pas pour répondre à votre
question la répartition par langues
pourquoi essentiellement pour des
raisons de sécurité de confidentialité
pour rendre nos opérations les plus
efficaces mais en revanche vous avez
parlé de pas citer monsieur le président
tous les trimestres tous les trimestres
nous publions un rapport complet sur
l'ensemble des actions qui sont menées
par ces technologies et par ses équipes
pour montrer les progrès ou encore les
défis que nous avons pour améliorer la
modération sur nos plateformes je crois
pouvoir vous dire qu'il y à peu
d'entreprises digital dans le monde mais
j'ai c'est notre responsabilité qui ont
fait autant d'efforts depuis de
nombreuses années pour améliorer cette
efficacité l'union européenne d'ailleurs
à publier une étude il ya maintenant
deux ans et a montré que sous 24 heures
facebook est l entreprise la plus
efficace qui retire est en effet
extrêmement vite les les contenus donc
voilà ce que nous avons fait sur la
modération est fort important mais je
veux lui aussi communication et vous
évoquez transparence puisque nous avons
un rapport trimestriel
si la commission souhaite voir le
dernier jeu voulant verrai avec plaisir
sur la transparence des algorithmes nous
essayons là aussi d'aller le plus loin
possible vous le comprendrez aussi
il y a des éléments qui sont
difficilement publiables si j'ose dire
c'est difficile de rentrer en vente pour
des raisons aussi de sécurité et
d'efficacité de nos outils il y a
parfois des organisations des structures
qui cherchent à utiliser nos plateformes
de façon malicieuse
et nous d'ailleurs nous
interrompons régulièrement des
tentatives interférences sur nos
plateformes
depuis 2010 est ses 150 opérations
d'interférences qui ont été stoppés et
dès que nous le savons nous le rendrons
public il ya des choses qui ne nous
semble-t-il ne peuvent pas être rendue
transparente néanmoins pour les
utilisateurs nous cherchons à leur
expliquer de façon le plus précise et
avec des outils de contrôle j'en ai cité
quelques-uns tout à l'heure comment
fonctionnent les algorithmes et
notamment sur chaque poste que vous
voyez sur facebook ou sur instagram sur
chaque contenu qui est mis sur votre fil
d'actualité en cliquant un clic une fois
en haut à droite vous allez voir ils
allaient comprendre pourquoi vous voyez
ce poste c'était qu'on vous explique en
réalité comment fonctionnent les
algorithmes et on vous donne des outils
de contrôle extrêmement simple à
utiliser et d'ailleurs nous faisons des
campagnes de communication et nous
poussons les gens à les utiliser pour
savoir comment fonctionnent les
algorithmes donc nous essayons maximum
de donner accès à ces outils à tous les
utilisateurs pour qu'ils puissent
comprendre pourquoi ils voient ce type
de contenu ce soit des contenus de vos
amis de contenu de marque si c'est une
publicité où tant d'autres contenus
pourquoi vous les voyez est-ce que vous
souhaitez les voir est-ce que vous
souhaitez les masquer et quel type même
d'information vous avez donné où sont
utilisés par un pour vous ciblez long
terme de plus de deux publicités et on
vous donne aussi le contrôle c'est
l'outil de gestion des préférences
publicitaires qui vous permet d'écarter
des marques et des entreprises parce que
vous ne souhaitez pas qu'elle vous le
parle ou alors de comprendre pourquoi
vous avez été ciblés quels centres
d'intérêts chez vous a intéressé telle
ou telle entreprise
ces paroles mais collègue monique de
marco
c'est donc les questions ont déjà été
posées mais par contre je reviens sur
quelque chose que vous avez annoncé tout
à l'heure le lancement d'un espace dédié
aux entreprises de presse facebook
facebook news oui qui rendrait un
service tiers des sous aux éditeurs et
aux utilisateurs pouvez vous nous en
dire un peu plus à ce sujet
et après je me lance dans une question
un peu particulière match et j'ai vu que
au mois de février facebook vous avez
perdu de la valeur en bourse près de 200
milliards et donc une valeur qu'on peut
considérer en moins pour les annonces
publicitaires
qui serait une principale source de
revenus
les utilisateurs sont tentés d'aller
voir d'autres canaux et si vous perdez
utilisateurs
donc vous avez aussi des utilisateurs
qui vieillissent et puisque facebook
n'est pas très utilisé par les moins de
25 ans même 30 ans qui préfère d'autres
réseaux sociaux comme tik tok par
exemple qu'est-ce que vous pouvez miser
comme croissance allez vous de vous
développer vers le métal verre ou alors
avez vous des projets de croissance
externe de rachat par exemple comme vous
l'avait fait précédemment en restant
adapté à ce qu'elle craint
m et merci à madame la sénatrice alors
facebook nous merci de revenir là dessus
comme je le disais tout à l'heure en
introduction où on pourrait pourtant
monsieur le rapporteur le fil
d'actualité de facebook n'est pas
le lieu naturel et de destination de
l'information il aurait en réalité très
minoritaire mais nous avons souhaité
pour deux éléments créer un espace et
est pas loin est-ce que vous utilisez
facebook vous même
heureusement oui heureusement oui
heureusement j'essaie de jouer ces deux
je vais essayer de vous convaincre que
c'est bien avec les plus de 25 ans
vous avez d'autres fonctionnalités à
côté de ce fil d'actualité
par exemple la fonctionnalité qu'on
appelle facebook watch où vous allez
retrouver l'ensemble des vidéos postées
par toutes les personnes entreprises que
vous soulevez parmi nous allons lancer
prochainement un nouvel espace que nous
avions annoncé il ya quelques mois qui
s'appelle facebook news qui va être
réservé uniquement à la publication de
l'ensemble des médias que vous suivez
vous suivez sur votre aujourd'hui sur
votre facebook à vous beaucoup de médias
il ya cet espace sera uniquement
réservée à l'information publiée par des
éditeurs par des entreprises de médias
par des entreprises de presse nationale
nous leur avons proposé de rejoindre
cette fonctionnalité beaucoup beaucoup
en effet on rejoint ça permet si vous
voulez de donner aux utilisateurs une
destination nature naturel pour
l'information est nous semble-t-il aussi
deuxième intérêt j'ai fait un deuxième
objectif de lutter alors contre des
informations moins fiable parce que vous
allez avoir un espace où vous allez
avoir les informations comme sur le fil
d'actualité vous pourrez ensuite
organiser cet espace qui se présente
comme un fil d'actualités à côté du fil
d'actualité si vous souhaitez d'abord
voir les informations sportives comme
dans un journal vous pourrez
sélectionner le chapitre des
informations sportives si c'est la
politique qu'elle sera la politique
économique etc c'est un
fonctionnaire et qui est utilisée
fonctionne très bien aux états unis et
en grande bretagne et qui arrive bientôt
en france /
la capitalisation boursière je parle pas
beaucoup de réponses vous connaissez le
fonctionnement des marchés financiers on
a annoncé nos résultats on a annoncé
aussi les perspectives de croissance
pour le premier trimestre ont
manifestement les investisseurs ont
trouvé que ce n'était pas exactement ce
qu'ils attendaient donc le marché à
corriger c'est arrivé et ça arrive dans
l'histoire des entreprises
sur les vous poser deux questions
d'abord merci madame la sénatrice de
dire que nous sommes en effet dans un
environnement concurrentiel et
compétitif notamment sur les jeunes vous
avez raison et monsieur le rapporteur
m'interroger toutes saoulées ailleurs
sur les jeunes nous sommes dans un
environnement digital que nous appelons
depuis plusieurs années multi
applications facebook est né il ya 18
ans
instagram a été racheté par facebook
2000 2012 et il y a depuis de nombreuses
applications et de nombreux services
sociaux qui sont nés avec des produits
attractifs intelligent et qui rassemble
en effet beaucoup de millions
d'utilisateurs ce sont des compétiteurs
ce sont des entreprises évidemment de
qualité et notre travail en permanence
de faire en sorte que les gens utilisent
plutôt nos produits qu'ils aillent voir
évidemment la concurrence facebook
rassemble encore beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes instagram également
mais en effet le paysage digital a
profondément changé depuis maintenant
cinq six années vous avez cité des
entreprises qui connaissent un succès
charge à nous par notre innovation par
nos produits à montrer que nous sommes
une entreprise attractive quelles sont
nos projets vous l'avait cité en
changeant de nom il ya maintenant
quelques mois l'entreprise a aussi
annoncé qu'elle voulait investir et
construire ce qu'on appelle les univers
de metaverse saisir des univers virtuels
des espaces virtuels où vous pourrez
avoir des expériences dans des univers
qui vont être créés
c'est au delà de notre entreprise un
très grand mouvement de l'industrie
digitale et d'entreprises très fort
d'ailleurs dans notre pays où beaucoup
aujourd'hui d'entreprise investis sur
ces espaces virtuels qui vont être créés
des marques s'y intéresse de jeunes
entreprises & start up française
extrêmement prometteuse d'ailleurs en
bas déjà des univers virtuels pour un
certain nombre d'utilisateurs ou de
marges parle à 100 je pense par noah
sandbox donc oui nous avons engagé c'est
ça notre stratégie industrielle c'est
d'être un des éléments et des
entreprises si possible leader de ce
nouveau nouvelle révolution digitale
mais vous le savez le métavers s'il y
aurait en fait des mé averses et toutes
les entreprises pourront y aller nous
verrons dans les années qui viennent
comment ces espaces pourront être ou pas
interopérables entre mais oui c'est la
nouvelle frontière certainement la
révolution digitale
assez la parole à michel le j'ai juste
une petite parenthèse mais puisque vous
nous inviter à regarder les éléments de
classement sur le fil jeu
l'information je les fais effectivement
il ya bien comment et déterminer l'ordre
des publications tant que sur une
premiers pas le genre en français et on
vous propose d'en savoir plus sur le
fonctionnement du classement
personnalisé du fil et quand j'appuie je
tombe sur une page en anglais comme quoi
il ya encore des efforts et des progrès
non je crois que tout se tous ces
parenthèses je voulais vous seront à
regarder ensemble s'ils voulaient non
nous nous nous avons voir entre les deux
voies en revanche vous avez
son dont fonctionne en fait les
algorithmes et les contenus vous sont
adressées c'est exact c'est
effectivement une synthèse mais où
deuxième clic on tombe sur une page en
anglais ça j'ai
passé un quart de la miss la méthode
parce que lui tout est en français
michel logique merci monsieur le
président je soly on est dans un univers
qui évolue beaucoup l'univers des médias
avait que des transformations dans les
usages et beaucoup de choses
l'impression d'être dans la fable la
grenouille leboeuf l'impression que on
veut qu'on suit toujours des groupes de
plus en plus important est ce que
aujourd'hui avec le passé qui est le
vôtre dans dans les médias en france est
ce que vous envisagez pour aller
toujours le prolongement de ce qu'a dit
ma collègue monique di marco est ce que
vous allez est ce que vous seriez
intéressé par un rapprochement avec un
groupe audiovisuel ça c'est ma première
question ma deuxième question je vais et
rebondi parce que sélection je voulais
vous poser suite aux problèmes boursiers
que vous avez enregistré la semaine
dernière
je vais un peu plus loin quelles sont
les conséquences auxquelles seraient des
conséquences aujourd'hui au niveau
français avec aujourd'hui le manque à
gagner que vous avez au niveau mondial
quelles seraient les conséquences au
niveau de notre pays et troisième
question question revient toujours sur
les chiffres c'est bien le rapporteur
vous interroger le président vous a
interrogé là-dessus ce matin alors je
toujours les prendre au conditionnel
on nous aurait annoncé que vous seriez
sur le podium des recettes publicitaires
en troisième position sur donc le podium
français et vos recettes seraient
estimés à 1 milliard 4 est-ce que vous
pouvez nous confirmer ce chiffre même si
on va la voir dans quelques jours mais
puisqu'on est dans une sorte d' enquête
je pense que les résultats vous avez
déjà deux hommes déjà la mi février
je pensais que vous quelque chose qui va
sortir dans quinze jours vous devez
sûrement être courant voilà mes trois
questions merci soldats des poèmes cela
est avéré c'est difficile pour moi vous
donner le chiffre précis qui va être
publié et vous verrez où nous en sommes
je peux vous dire à peu près quelle est
la tendance de la croissance puisque
nous appuyer notre croissance mondiale
et vous verrez vraiment les résultats de
facebook france dans notre pays sur
votre premier point
industriellement est ce que vous pensez
à des rapprochements en france où
peut-être d'ailleurs peut-être pardon
ailleurs avec des groupes audiovisuels
ce n'a jamais été la stratégie de notre
entreprise
ni en europe ni aux etats-unis nous
avons opéré
de stratégie de cette nature nous sommes
toujours restés
sur une stratégie industrielle qui
revient au fond à l'origine de facebook
et à sa mission première
qui est de connecter les gens et de
connecter le monde toutes les
entreprises qui ont été rachetés par
facebook les plus connus sont instagram
et what's app sont tous dans cet
objectif là et aucune entreprise de
médias traditionnels n'a jamais été
racheté par notre entreprise et je crois
que nos stratégies demeure au contraire
nous venons en parler avec votre
collègue notre stratégie telle qu'elle a
été dévoilée par marc zuckerberg il ya
quelques mois c'est vraiment d'être une
entreprise pionniers si possible leader
dans ce qu'on appelle le nouvel univers
des méta vers ce qui va arriver et qui a
commencé d'ailleurs à se construire de
par le monde sur le manque à gagner
il s'agit du cours de bourse et de la
capitalisation boursière en effet
l'action est tombée
ça s'est produit dans l'histoire de
cette entreprise moi je suis là depuis
presque neuf ans j'ai vécu des moments
où l'entreprise a vu son cours de bourse
tomber ça n'a pas un impact aujourd'hui
dans le travail que nous faisons
[Musique]
l'activité commerciale qui elano
d'ailleurs vous avez pu voir où je
pourrais mettre à la disposition de
votre commission les résultats annuels
de notre entreprise ont fait une belle
croissance les chiffres de 2021 a été
solide donc évidemment comme vous le
savez il ya pas de rapport direct entre
l'activité du quotidien que nous menons
et le cours de bourse qui a été affectée
ça s'est produit ça serait pour beaucoup
d'entreprises hier il reprenait je crois
à peu près 5% mais encore un peu à
reprendre mais ça n'a pas d'impact sur
l'activité du quotidien de notre
entreprise aujourd'hui ni en france ni
ailleurs bien sûr
sylvie robert
oui merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur
vous avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur
soli nous sommes pas un éditeur nous
sommes une grande plate-forme
responsable une question avec une
réponse très précise est ce que vous
vous considérez comme un média
non madame la sénatrice pas comme un
média pour pour les raisons profondes
qui dans la tranche des questions du
rapporteur je vais continuer je vous
remercie tout à l'heure ce matin lors de
nos auditions on a parlé de la donner
vous imaginez bien que c'est une valeur
inestimable est très importante parler
du coeur du réacteur le coeur du
réacteur on l'a dit tout à l'heure pour
vous c'est l'algorithme
et je pense que le vôtre a peut-être
plus d'impact est d'importance que
certains autres au regard de l'impact
qu'il a pu avoir ou peut avoir sur des
processus démocratique je voudrais
savoir comment il a évolué
cet algorithme quels paramètres concrets
vous avez mis en place pour garantir une
pluralité une diversité de l'information
jeudi d'autant plus parce que tout à
l'heure vous nous avez dit ça c'est
intéressant j'aimerais vraiment
finalement c'est vous qui êtes votre
propre producteur d'information au sens
vous facebook l'algorithme c'était à la
question de notre rapporteur
ne donne pas une diversité
d'informations mais va forcément parce
que vous avez regardé tel ou tel titre
vous avez regardé tel ou tel poste vous
avez regardé va flécher en fait on vous
profil votre information donc ce n'est
absolument pas d'hiver dans la mesure où
on est presque et je le dirai une façon
assez
assez paradoxal on est presque notre
propre producteur dans notre enfermement
intellectuel je peux le dire comme ça
c'est un peu
derrière cela il ya des impacts qui sont
des impacts forcément
je peux le dire idéologique mais aussi
des impacts économiques liées à la
question de la publicité à la question
d'autres on va dire conséquence sur sûr
sur cette façon forcément de procéder si
je vous ai posé la première question
comme un média vous avez bien compris
que la deuxième question que je ne veux
poser n'est pas anodine par rapport à la
première
donc j'attends vraiment savoir comment
vous répondez à la deuxième pour qu'on
puisse nous mêmes nous faire notre
propre jugement sur ce que vous
qualifiez ou pas de médias
pardon merci dans la cendre risque
sur le pluralisme
est le thème que vous abordez celui de
l'enfermement qu'on appelle aussi les
bulles algorithmique et c'est absolument
d'abord nous pensons là aussi
profondément et de nombreuses études
l'ont même nom ont été menées ont
souligné des études ailleurs
indépendante que
nous favorisons le pluralisme et
l'ouverture sur le monde parme des
outils qui sont mis gratuitement à la
disposition aujourd'hui deux milliards
de personnes
nous aidons d'ailleurs le plus possible
j'ai donné des exemples pour les médias
ici dans notre pays à ce que ce
pluralisme
vive à aider les médias traditionnels à
s'adapter et à adapter leur modèle
économe à del économique pardon au monde
digital ou à favoriser la naissance de
nouveaux médias digitaux eux-mêmes tout
à l'heure sur la porter on en a parlé
ensemble je reviens sur cette idée brut
par exemple qui est un succès mondial
aujourd'hui est une entreprise française
qui est l'année dernière a rassemblé
plus de 7 milliards de vues qui est un
énorme succès en inde un énorme succès
aux états unis est une entreprise
française et moi je crois au contraire
que les entreprises françaises de médias
ont un rôle très important à jouer
beaucoup d'opportunités et que nous
favorisons ce pluralisme sur les sur les
bulles jeu 13 objectivement ici à votre
question je vais préparer des éléments
là dessus parce que je crois c'est un
sujet extrêmement complexe qui a été
étudiée qui a été étudié par de
nombreuses universités centres de
recherche indépendants parmi les plus
prestigieux le sociologue lui-même
français dominique cardon qui est un des
spécialistes de ces questions vous le
connaissez considère d'ailleurs que les
plateformes sociales ne participent pas
ou qu'il n'existe quasiment pas de bulle
et que la polarisation se fait bien
avant
j'ai plusieurs études que je veux vous
citez je ne peux pas tous les citer
parce qu'elles seront un peu trop longue
mais la royal society au royaume uni
avec oxford et reuters ont mené des
études et ils montraient très clairement
dans leurs conclusions quand on avait
rien ne permet d'établir cette hypothèse
des bulles rien ne permet de l'établir
et que certaines halles permettait
d'avoir un accès plus large à diverses
opinions à diverses informations et au
contraire loin de vous enfermez vous
vous ouvrez je me rappelle une étude à
standford de standford pardon qui avait
été menée il y avait mais avait été
menée sur le territoire américain et
avait montré que les populations les
plus polarisé
étaient celles qui utilisaient le moins
internet
je ne réponds pas le sais triste en
en vous en vous disant que ce n'est pas
un sujet complexe néanmoins
toutes les grandes universités tous les
grands centres de recherche je vous en
ai cités il y en a d'autres n'ont jamais
établi cela de notre expérience de notre
propre expérience
nous pensons vraiment qu'au contraire
nos plateformes ouvre sur la diversité
d'ailleurs si vous vous rappelez comment
nous avions accès à l'information il ya
vingt ans je ne suis pas certain que si
vous aviez des idées vraiment arrêter et
des idées économiques ou politiques
quand vous achetiez tel type de journaux
je ne décide pas vous preniez au kiosque
exactement l'opposé j'observe qu'au
contraire les idées circulent
la liberté d'expression parfois qu'on
nous reproche est garanti et là aussi et
si vous à vous intéresse je le mettrai à
la disposition de la commission toutes
ses études vous le voyez ce ne sont pas
des études de facebook qui ont en
permanence en permanence ou de très
grands sociologues j'ai sollicité
dominique cardon ont cherché à montrer
qu'en réalité il n'y avait pas de bulle
il n'y avait pas d'enfermement ce n'est
pas à dire qu'il n'ya pas de
polarisation dans les sociétés vous avez
raison mais de démontrer l'impact
d'internet où l'impact des réseaux
sociaux où l'impact des médias
traditionnels n'est pas si évident je
termine sur l'étude d'adp harvard qui a
été mené en amont de l'élection
américaine de 2001 et qui a montré que
les éléments de polarisation les plus
importants étaient apportées par le
média télévision
donc juste pour vous dire que nous
pensons que nous gagnerons ils sont le
pluralisme et nous pensons que sur ces
sujets parfois on tend à donner cette
vérité pas vous bien sûr qu'en fait les
études montrent une plus grande
complexité tendent souvent à dire
linverse tendent souvent à dire linverse
et notamment la dernière de que j'ai
cités où la première unité de la royal
society a montré qu'il n'avait aucune
preuve de l'existence de ces phénomènes
rapide alors parce que
répondu à ma question de collègues qui
veulent poser les rails pardon j'avais
que de 1
est ce que ces dernières années on va
dire ces deux dernières années c'est
important parce que c'est lié williams
et modifier oui oui oui alors quand
l'algorithme et pardon excusez moi je
l'avais noté j'ai pas attendu avec sous
la main oui et quand c'est fait nous
nous le disons la grande modification de
l'algorithme de facebook a eu lieu en
2016 début 2016 et on l'a appelé au
pardon je vais le traduit en français où
va il s'est appelé meaningful sochaux
d'interruption c'était pour favoriser
les interactions sociales qui avait le
plus de deux sens pour nos utilisateurs
et notamment de recentrer le fil
d'actualité dont l'algorithme sur les
publications de vos amis et de vos
proches et de membres de votre famille -
que des publications externes dont les
médias mais pas que les médias à chaque
fois que la logan l'algorithme est
modifié et quand il les modifications
significatives on explique en effet cela
je reviens quand même sur un point qui
est important et le président à tester
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez vous
décider précisément de ce que vous
voulez voir au vent en priorité dans
votre fil d'actualité mais oui quand il
ya des modifications la plus importante
de la dernière la plus importante était
celle de cette année là pierre laurent
oui merci monsieur se lit j'ai plusieurs
questions rapidement la première qui
était peut-être pas la plus importante
mais c'est une précision ce qui au début
de votre propos vous avez vous avez
valorisé au fil de votre propose que
vous apportiez comme richesse aux médias
donc vous permet-il et conclure vous
avez dit à un moment donné
180 milliards de clics diriger vers les
éditeurs parents et ça équivaut à je
crois 6 milliards de
j'ai bien noté le chiffre que vous avez
donnée douceur ces chiffres de
valorisation sont des produits c'est
vous ils sont des études que nous avons
faites seul qui dit ça votant non sur
des études que nous avons faites sur
l'analyse de sur une année de nos
clients n'ont cédé ce sont des études
que nous avons faites que nous avons
publié sur l'impact et comment les
médias utilisait et pourrait favoriser
ce qu'on avait les liens entrants sur le
site quand vous quand vous utilisez
facebook et vous êtes une entreprise de
médias mais je vais vite vous le savez
nous publier des contenus en général
pour aller vraiment au bout du contenu
vous cliquez vous être envoyé sur le
site c'est ça que nous avons étudiés
c'est les chiffres que nous avons
données sont des études 12 a en fait
j'ai bien compris ce que vous chiffrer
mais le chiffre c'est vous qui le
produisent est quoi oui ce sont nos
études hockey deuxième deuxième question
toujours sur cette question hébergeurs
et je suis très étonné de la réponse que
vous avez fait à ce très directement à
ma collègue en disant vous n'êtes pas un
média
puisque au delà du débat hébergeur
éditeur vous êtes à proprement parler un
créateur d'information
et et du point de vue du sujet qui nous
intéresse c'est à dire les relations
entre autres aux tentations et
démocratie c'est même extrêmement
important parce que là toute
l'information vous créez à une grande
caractéristique qui peut d'ailleurs posé
un problème à tous les médias c'est que
c'est une information quand même que
vérifier quand je dis peut vérifier et
là je parle pas seulement des fake nous
c'est à dire des choses qui sont
délibérément construite pour être des
forces d'information ça c'est une chose
mais au-delà de ça beaucoup
d'informations circulent dans les
réseaux sociaux qui ne sont pas
vérifiées et qui pourtant vu la
puissance
qui est la vôtre s'imposent comme des
données du débat public et qui oblige
d'ailleurs très souvent à ce qu'on est
ce que la presse qui fait son métier
est obligé d'essayer de vérifier si ce
qui
ici la rumeur qui s'est enflé est vrai
ou pas tellement à la circuler sur les
réseaux sociaux donc vous comprenez bien
que de ce point de vue-là je dirais
presque même en étant provocateur vous
êtes quelque part aussi un perturbateur
d'information par moments donc c'est
pour ça que la question de la
transparence des algorithmes sur le
contrôle ou pas de ce qui circule et est
une question du point de vue
démocratique quand même assez
fondamental
ma dernière question c'est parce que
j'en avais une quatrième je vais la
laisser tomber
c'est je reviens sur cette question du
montant ont persisté à dire qu'il est
parfaitement normal qu'ils soient secret
à propos des accords que vous avez passé
avec la presse mais vous comprenez bien
que ça pose ça nous pose à nous les
législateurs un très gros problème parce
que nous votons une loi pourquoi sur
cette question parce qu'il ya un
problème de mutualisation de la valeur
si ces chiffres sont inconnues comment
est-ce que nous évaluons la portée du
dispositif législatif
que nous avons adoptées pour voir si
effectivement il contribue un partage de
la valeur tels que nous l'envisagions
avec la loi ou pas donc là il ya quand
même un problème de transparence qui
pour les législateurs que nous sommes
pose un très sérieux problème et à ce
propos j'avais une sous question c'est
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
puisque vous avez dit qu'il y avait dans
ces accords des accords directs entre
certains éditeurs et vous et une partie
mutualisé quelle est la répartition de
ça est ce que c'est principalement des
accords entre quelques gros éditeurs et
vous des choses mutualisé parce que du
point de vue de la démocratie c'est pas
la même chose qu'un des gros problèmes
des dispositifs en matière de médias en
matière de presse c'est que l'ensemble
des acteurs puissent profiter de la fin
puis ce mutualiser la richesse créée et
permettre à tous les acteurs manière
pluraliste de se développer ce qui est
évidemment par rapport à la bécane isme
de concentration est pour nous une
question essentielle
beaucoup de questions pourquoi je
réponds sur la question des éditeurs ou
des médias que nous ne sommes pas ce que
nous ne pensons pas être ce type
d'acteurs tel que nous l'entendons j'ai
d'ailleurs dit que nous pensons être de
un acteur d'une autre nature créée
depuis maintenant plusieurs années par
le développement de l'activité numérique
et des grandes plateformes parce que
vous l'avez très bien dit d'ailleurs
vous vous dites vous êtes un cas vous
créez de l'information je veux vous le
dire nous ne créons pas de l'information
et c'est pour ça que le terme d'éditeurs
ou de médias qui recoupe essentiellement
cette activité et si vous entendez
médias mettre en relation deux personnes
il va créer de l'information monsieur le
sénateur nom des gens qui utilisent nos
plateformes je reviens sur la
responsabilité et l'information utilise
la plateforme pour créer de
l'information créée de du contenu mais
un contenu c'est une photo d'un week-end
c'est une vidéo de ses vacances c'est en
effet je vous ai donné le chiffre une
partie des activités des groupes de
médias mais qui est extrêmement
extrêmement extrêmement minoritaire donc
pour ce point là je ne peux pas vous
suivre sur ce point vous vous dites vous
créez de l'information non nous ne
créons pas et aucun salarié dans cette
entreprise en france ou ailleurs dans le
monde n'a comme métier de créer de
l'information en revanche et c'est là où
la nature nouvelle est la spécificité de
notre métier ou la spécialité de notre
responsabilité amène des réponses que
nous avons développé depuis des années
sur à la fois la modération
l'interdiction d'un type de contenu le
dialogue d'ailleurs permanent permanent
avec les autorités démocratiques où les
autorités de régulation le csa
aujourd'hui l'art comme vous le savez
une compétence sur par exemple le sujet
des fausses informations le travail avec
des partenaires certifiés reconnu nous
outils parle de lutte contre les fausses
informations
ont en partie comme élément les
partenariats avec des facs shaker qui
sont des entreprises de médias certifiés
dans le monde y en a plus de 80 c'est
d'ailleurs une activité qui est
d'initier en france nous cherchons à
répondre à cette nature particulière par
en effet des moyens des règles et des
partenariats
sur le chiffre de nos accords je
comprends j'ai énormément de respect
pour le législateur c'est très difficile
pour pour moi je reviens sur ce que je
vous ai dit de vous les donner ne
serait-ce que parce que des négociations
sont en cours on a évoqué notamment la
spm sur les magazines ou d'autres
organismes de gestion collective ses
traites c'est très difficile de vous les
donner c'est très difficile de vous les
donner et je suis au regret de vous dire
que je ne peux pas publiquement cet
après midi vous préciser cela sur le
collectif et l'individuel
ce n'est pas nous qui avons choisi cela
c'est à dire que certains groupes de
presse je peux citer le groupe le monde
puisqu'il a été dit par le président du
directoire du monde lui-même a choisi
dans ce sujet là pour ce sujet là
d'avoir des négociations individuelles
au titre de son entreprise et qu'ils
considéraient qu'il avait lui-même à
négocier ses draps loi ces droits là
pardon et son exécution avec un certain
nombre d'acteurs
l'alliance de la presse a reçu mandat
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs c'est
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'acteurs et
à partir du moment où le mandat a été
donné à une association collectif un
organisme collectif nous avons fait et
choisit la dimension collective mais
vous comprenez bien sûr le sénateur ce
n'est pas nous qui avons choisi un job à
toi ça sera comme ça où tout cela donc
individuelles collectives c'est
important de lire ses les acteurs qui
ont choisi par perdre jamais si on
choisit mais vous le savez le mode de
négociation avec nous et le mode
d'interaction qu'on transfère ensuite
sans nous donner les montants et soins
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire si on
proportions ce qui pèse le plus lourd
dans les accords que vous êtes blessé
les accords avec certains milhas où
c'est l'accord collectif ce que je peux
vous dire c'est tous ces accords ont été
justes ont été équitable on a toujours
vu viser une répartition équitable de
tous les acteurs quel qu'ait été leur
mode de discussion à leur mode de
négociation toujours et d'ailleurs
certains éléments de la négociation ont
été définis préalablement avec ces
acteurs eux mêmes kate qui était je
prenais le temps mais parfois
extrêmement compliqué parce que je veux
vous dire je comprends bien que vous
souhaitiez régime et que tous ces
négociations ont toujours été menés
c'est dans cet état d'esprit je sais un
point d c'est bien des fois qu'on avance
sur des points très précis vous n'êtes
pas complètement répondu c'est toujours
sur la vocation à ce que je vous ai
presque proposés si aujourd'hui un
éditeur qui a passé un accord avec vous
ou une alliance qui a passé un accord
avec a envie de publier le montant de
l'accord est ce que vous voulez punissez
ou pas
c'est à dire est ce que vous voulez
délié c'est bien plus que cela vous
dites moi je peux pas bon est ce que
l'on voulait santerre 6e jeu del cette
transparence est ce que vous ne dénoncez
pas lachor parce qu'il le rende plus
c'est ça que je vous demande d'abord en
effet nous avons des clauses de
confidentialité avec nos partenaires si
un souhaitait leur antre d'accord
laissez moi s'il vous plaît c'est le
rapporteur et je pourrai revenir vers la
commission par écrit voir avec nos
services juridiques si nous pouvons le
faire ou pas c'est un élément sensible
notamment dans le contexte actuel hunan
où je le redis nous n'avons pas terminé
terminer nos négociations or nous avons
toujours souhaité négocier d'eau si vous
le souhaitez précisément si vous donnez
quelques jours je répondrais devant
l'autre commission en ayant vous
comprenez préalablement discuté avec les
équipes juridiques de l'entreprise
alors il reste deux derniers
intervenants evelyne renault garabédian
et bling vous entendez oui nous entend
merci monsieur le président
bonjour monsieur je voudrais revenir sur
l'avenir si vous voulez bien
dans la mesure du possible bien entendu
le grand projet de facebook qui explique
d'ailleurs son changement de nom est le
méta pers vous avez commencé à aborder
tout à l'heure dans un pré c'est donc
questionnements qui nous a été fait
j'aimerais surtout savoir si vous avez
réfléchi aux conséquences pour la
démocratie d'un tel projet car si demain
nous sommes en mesure de participer
virtuellement un concert on pourra tout
aussi facilement participer à un meeting
politique ou bien autre chose capable de
modifier en profondeur les rapports
sociaux et à tous une idée aujourd'hui
du rôle dans des médias dans le but
adverse merci de votre réponse
merci d'autres questions madame la
sénatrice oh oui la réponse est oui et
en annonçant le projet du metavers sur
tout cas pour notre entreprise est
d'ailleurs préalablement à l'annonce de
mark zuckerberg lui-même
nous avons annoncé qu'il fallait
immédiatement et en amont réfléchir à
ces questions
démocratiques sociales éthiques qui vont
se poser et qui se pose presque déjà
dans cet univers du metavers c'est pour
cela nous avons annoncé en 2020 que nous
allions nouer des partenariats avec des
universités des chercheurs dans le monde
entier en asie en europe aux états unis
et que nous nous dotions se fondent
analyse ce fond de réflexion d'un
montant de 50 millions de dollars donc
oui nous réfléchissons à cela et vous
avez raison ce sont des questions
importantes vous évoquez si je peux me
permettre de compléter ce sont des
questions que nous nous traitons
j'allais dire aujourd'hui sur le sujet
bien sûr extrêmement vaste de de la
démocratie des débats je donne deux
exemples nous avons par exemple des
dispositifs spécifiques aujourd'hui à
l'endroit plutôt des jeunes pour les
inciter pour les élections à venir dans
notre pays à s'informer à se renseigner
à s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
et pour toutes les grandes élections
dans le monde depuis des années nous
avons des dispositifs civique et citoyen
pour inciter les jeunes à aller
s'inscrire et à le faire pour toutes les
élections nous avons fait cela en france
en 2019 et nous avons mesuré que cela
avait permis d'inscrire sur les listes
électorales en tout cas que cinq cent
mille personnes avaient cliqué pour
aller s'informer sur les listes
électorales dont en permanence nous
cherchons à informer par des dispositifs
extrêmement large sur les actions de
civiques pendant les élections
mais vous avez raison sur le métavers ce
sont des discussions que nous avons
d'ailleurs déjà engagé avec des experts
et des universités indépendante
dernière question de laurence farideh
merci monsieur le président monsieur
solide j'aimerais prolonger de deux
interventions de collègues le la
première c'est sur sept modèles
économiques qui est en train de se
dessiner en fait si on lit un peu les
les articles un peu académique sur sur
l'évolution on se rend compte en fait
que vous on parle de coopétition
c'est à dire qu'en fait vous êtes devenu
un peu les nouveaux kiosques
mondiaux de l'information et finalement
les les mutés
des instances d'information sont obligés
de passer par par vous et du coup on
voit bien est-ce que vous avez développé
sur sur la presse et les accords on
pourrait voir émerger un modèle
économique qui ressemble étrangement
parce que vous mettez la presse en état
de dépendance quelques pas et on
pourrait voir émerger un modèle
économique qui ressemble étrangement à
celui de la grande distribution et des
négociations avec avec les producteurs
et et une négociation par le prix qui
peut mettre en concurrence enfin qui
peut mettre en question la pluralité de
l'information
du fait de l'accès à ce que vous êtes un
c'est-à-dire des infos mais d'hyères et
donc ça pose un vrai problème de
structuration et de et de des données
démocratie et la deuxième est donc la
deuxième question en prolongement de
celle de sylvie robert et de pierre
laurent
vous vous acharnez en disant que vous
n'êtes pas des éditeurs il ya
actuellement un règlement européen qui
est en préparation sur la publicité
politique qui vise deux choses d'une
part la traçabilité et d'autre part la
transparence en matière notamment de
d'algorithmes et dancette ce règlement
ce qui est visé c'est en fait de bien
repérer la chaîne d'acteurs et de
d'aller vers une responsabilité
conjointe de tous les acteurs et dans
cette chaîne d'acteurs on voit bien
que l'éditeur il est il est responsable
mais le diffuseur du contenu est
responsable aussi donc deux fêtes vous
serez englober et c'est une manière de
pour la pour la commission européenne de
dire c'est une élément de réponse à la
question de la concentration et de la
pluralité de l'information et donc on
voit bien que la au niveau européen est
à côté de la traçabilité ya la
transparence par rapport aux algorithmes
et par rapport à la protection des
données personnelles qui obligeront à
fac et obligera le règlement obligera à
bien identifier
la collecte des données et l'utilisation
de ces données donc là il ya quelque
chose qui est en train de se mettre en
place aussi qui est une réponse
juridique
à un modèle économique qui est en train
d'évoluer et en fait on peut se noue se
poser la question de savoir est ce que
le problème c'est la concentration ou
est ce que c'est la maîtrise de l'outil
technologique
[Musique]
utilisée par l'un pour pour
l'information voila j'aimerais bien voir
votre votre réaction par rapport par
rapport à ça et le rapport à cette
évolution et notre collègue tout à leur
disait on parle d'avenir comment vous
vous stratégiquement vous intégrez ça et
vous répondez à assat imanquablement je
pense que la définition éditeurs
diffuseurs va être confondus à un moment
donné parce que ça sera une chaîne
d'acteurs responsables et donc ça va
mettre à bas toute votre stratégie de
vous de ne pas vous considérez comme
comme comme des éditeurs ou alors mal
merci madame la série ou alors dans le
débat européen vous avez raison de
l'évoquer
illustre bien et je le dis humblement la
complexité la complexité
de mettre notre entreprise dans tel
cadre ou tel cadre qui préexistait à la
révolution digitale et c'est ça que je
veux en fait vous dire hey hey hey hey
hey je crois d'ailleurs les discussions
à bruxelles depuis de nombreuses années
ont cherché à comprendre quelle était la
nature nouvelles de notre entreprise de
tant d'autres et quelles étaient les
responsabilités et au delà comment
mettre un cadre de régulation nous avons
d'ailleurs été je crois la première
entreprise à
dire non mais ans aux états unis mark
zuckerberg lui-même à bruxelles il ya
quelques années qu'il fallait que la
régulation
nouvelle s'adapte à l'ère digitale
et qu'il fallait que les autorités
démocratiquement élues que les
régulateurs ça commence à être le cas se
saisisse de ces sujets car ce sujet ne
pouvait pas être uniquement celles de
nos entreprises sinon ce n'est pas le
cas nos règles d'une entreprise privée
pourrait devenir alors les règles de la
société ce que nous ne voulons pas donc
nous avons nous même menacé dry toujours
plaidé pour une régulation
pour une régulation j'allais dire
adaptées efficaces à l'ère digitale
parce que nous avons eu des tentatives
de régulation avec quelques années
beaucoup de pays en france en allemagne
qui en fait ne répondait pas
complètement à l'évolution donc en tout
cas c'est difficile il ya deux questions
je vais y venir de répondre à l'avion
mais oui sur la régulation oui sur
l'adaptation des règles avec aussi une
nécessité que la régulation permettent
encore et de façon très développer
l'innovation des entreprises qui a pas
que nous il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
européennes et françaises qui deviennent
ou peuvent devenir des acteurs majeurs
du digital à travers le monde vous
donner un exemple
et merci c'est la dernière question par
faire la publicité politique
eh bien nous avons été la première
entreprise il ya maintenant cinq ans je
regarde mais mes collègues je crois 5 en
2022 louis a changé complètement les
règles de la publicité politique et
justement à les rendre totalement
transparente vous avez une tron appelle
une librairie chez facebook sur facebook
qui est accessible par tous les
utilisateurs du monde y compris si vous
n'êtes pas utilisateurs de facebook qui
va vous donner la liste de toutes les
publicités politiques publiés dans tel
et tel pays et vous saurez quand la
publicité entre guillemets politique a
été publié quel territoire a été visé
quels groupes de personnes ont été
ciblés qui a financé la publicité
politique bien sûr les règles
s'appliquant en france sur la règle
électorale s'applique dans l'entreprise
mais pour vous dire que justement sur ce
sujet nous avons beaucoup réfléchi et
qu'on voulait faire une publicité qui
est classée pour nous d'ordre politique
c'est dans la vie de la cité il faut
d'abord demander l'autorisation de
pouvoir le faire et que nous avons exclu
depuis longtemps par exemple des
entreprises ou des personnes ou des
groupes de personnes qui veulent faire
de la publicité politique d'un pays à un
autre pour éviter parfois des intérieurs
sont c'est un très bon exemple mais là
aussi notre entreprise a essayé
d'innover et de sur la publicité
politique d'associer transparence
autorisation et pour que chacun puisse
vérifier ce qui se passe et c'est un
très bon exemple qui montre si vous
voulez que et c'est en tout cas ce que
je si j'ai un message étape vous m'aurez
entendu c'est que ce sont mon entreprise
notre entreprise et responsables sur ces
sujets et a toujours voulu entretenir un
dialogue constructif et a poussé der les
autorités notamment en france où un
livre blanc avaient été publiés sur la
régulation moderne du digital il y a
maintenant quatre ans pour comprendre
ces phénomènes parce que bien sûr il
faut une régulation vous avez raison
nous la demandons mais une faute de
régulation adaptée à notre temps qui a
tant changé premier point j'y reviens
vous dites est ce que vous ne risquez
pas au fond de mettre les entreprises de
presse ou la sous la dépendance je crois
même la cédraie exactement le contraire
et je vais vous dire pourquoi et je vous
le dis pardon l'expression la plus
rapide humblement
parce que les entreprises en réalité
deux médias ont un avenir extrêmement
fort à l'ère digitale
contrairement souvent à ce que les
médias traditionnels ont cru ou ce que
parfois vous pouvez entendre elles ont
une opportunité de développement car le
contenu vidéo le contenu d'ailleurs un
format informationnel ou informatif n'a
jamais été autant consommé aux raisons
une marque et des clients
est ce que montre l'exemple du monde
avec lequel nous avons travaillé depuis
près de six ans et vous pourrez
interroger ou à moins qu'il soit déjà
venu le président du directoire louis
dreyfus a montré surtout que notre rôle
était de faire comprendre ce qu'était le
modèle digital la consommation digitale
et donc l'évolution des modèles
économiques le monde c'est une réussite
exceptionnelle pour notre pays la
naissance de les abonnements numériques
et le figaro suis pas ce que nous
faisons le même programme pour le figaro
et les échos et le parisien etc pour au
contraire au contraire qu'ils adaptent
eux mêmes nous nous sommes un partenaire
leur modèle économique à la réalité de
la consommation digitale parce que
c'était pas facile à comprendre parce
que nous nous rappelons tous qu'il y
avait plus de 15 ans certains hésitent
hésiter ennuis tout gratuitement sur
internet en pensant que la publicité
financerait tout eh bien non c'était pas
le modèle on ne s'agit pas de les blâmer
c'était difficile à comprendre donc en
réalité les partenariats avec les
grandes plateformes permettent aux
grands éditeurs permettent aux grands
groupes de presse français européens
américains de retrouver les voies et les
moyens de leur vie économique le monde a
publié de très bons résultats en 2021 et
donc de leurs seins à leur indépendance
le new york times
qui est une bande acteurs des médias et
internationaux pas la mienne a atteint
le chiffre de 10 millions d'abonnés
payants qui leur donne une indépendance
une liberté totale donc si vous voulez
au contraire je crois au contraire
profondément depuis longtemps que le
partenariat entre les médias installés
les plateformes est un partenariat
constructif
j'hésitais le groupe m6 qui a fait un
partenariat avec nous
vous connaissez le président du groupe
m6 s'il a fait un partenariat c'est
qu'il a vu un intérêt c'est bien naturel
pour son entreprise ont je crois
vraiment contraire à cet intérêt à cet
art est constructif de construire une
nouvelle valeur et surtout un nouveau
modèle je termine enfin sera un point
pour les médias traditionnels il revient
sur les exemples des grands médias
français qui ont réussi les médias
digitaux naissent de nouveaux sites
d'information j'ai cité brut et j'ai
cité combiné j'étais vous allez y en
aura d'autres notre rôle c'est de les
aider et là aussi c'est un élément dette
sur le pluralisme me semble-t-il est
toute dernière question si vous pouvez
être bref l'un et l'autre parce que nous
avons joué ni retard
aurait coûté plusieurs
sujets ont été
approfondis le bien entendu que entre
aucune régulation prévu pour vos modèles
et la régulation qui existaient pour la
presse et les médias
vous êtes demandeur d'une régulation le
problème est de savoir si c'est une
régulation qui va dérégulé ce qui était
déjà régulés pour s'adapter à vous ou si
vous vous allez rentrer dans le cadre
globalement des principes qui étaient
édictées pour les autres ça c'est
l'enjeu vous savez bien sûr les
régulations c'est exactement là où je
veux en venir sur ma dernière question
c'est que sur la question par exemple
tf1 m6 et les marchés pertinents c'est
bien ça qu'est l'enjeu c'est où on
réguler le marché du numérique vous
entends position dominante absolue avec
les autres plateformes
où on dit que le marché télévisée où il
ya des régulations
rentrer dans le numérique et ce fonds
voilà donc à un moment donné c'est à
chaque fois comme ça que l'on se pose en
ou bien sûr que les régulations ancien
ne fonctionne plus complètement mais que
les pas de régulation du tout c'est la
loi du plus fort et c'est la disparition
de la diversité donc ma question c'est
que en gros seins parce que on doit
faire les choses par soi même souvent
vous êtes globalement où je loue était
dit et c'est avec google à 75% du marché
publicitaire du numérique
en position donc assez dominante on va
dire
et si on fond les deux marchaient
télévisés et numériques des petits
calculs comme ça avec nos petits moyens
nous amènerait à 54% du marché
unifié tv numérique pour google
est-ce que ce que je vous ai demandé à
ce que vous étiez d'accord avec cette
fusion des deux marchés et donc répondre
positivement la demande de tf1 m6 c'est
parce que normalement eux nous disent
que c'est pour pouvoir assurer une
concurrence face à vous qui veulent
cette fusion or on me dit que vous vous
avez un intérêt à cette fusion
alors que s'est dirigée contre vous
parce que d'un coup je tombais sur un
marché où êtes mois en position de
monopole et d'abus de position dominante
et que cela vous facilitera la vie avec
l'autorité de la concurrence qu'est ce
que vous me répondez à sa
sueur rapporteur d'abord
respectueusement je veux pas vous
laisser dire que nous sommes ni un
monopole ou qu'on abusé d'une position
dominante et sur les 75 % mais on va pas
avoir la discussion moi ce sont des
chiffres que nous ne reconnaissons pas
dans le marché national
je reviens sur ce sujet et c'est dire si
ce n'est pas une entreprise de définir
un marché pertinent ou pas c'est à
l'autorité de concurrence elle va faire
son travail à la mener une enquête donc
je ne peux pas vous répondre ouais je ne
peux pas vous répondre là dessus et j'en
ai ni les compétences j'allais dire
d'equipe où les compétences
intellectuelles pour définir quels les
marchés perdant c'est vraiment le rôle
des autorités de concurrence c'est
d'ailleurs un élément classique à la
fois du droit de la concurrence et des
autorités de régulation de la
concurrence donc elle va faire son
travail qu'elle le fera extrêmement bien
je peux pas vous répondre autre chose
sûre sur sur ce point le premier mot que
vous avez évoquées vous évoquez
régulation et pertinents et marché
pertinent parlant je pense que c'est pas
ces deux sujets différents certes la
révolution est là pas dans la régulation
qu'on ait évoqué avec madame la
sénatrice votre collègue est une autre
et une autre régulation c'est à la
régulation
global sur la modération des contenus
c'est autre chose que moi dans mon
esprit je sépare et bien les deux que la
régulation qui exercent l'autorité de
concurrence sur le roi de la concurrence
et les marchés pertinence d'un marché
national pour moi ça c'est celle happen
mais je ne peux pas vous répondre là
dessus parce que ce n'est ni ma
compétence ni mon autorité de définir
des démarches et pertinent et sur les
parts de marché noir parler
merci monsieur celui merci monsieur le
président merci mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur sénateurs merci aux sur la
porte merci mes chers collègues on va
reprendre assez rapidement peut-être de
famille nude pour se dégourdir les
jambes mais sinon nous reprochons
rapidement avec à la veille